ce sont les états unis qui ont imposé la
question ukrainienne à l'agenda du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu juste avant
que moscou n'en prenne mardi sa
présidence pour un mois l'objectif
isoler la russie accusé de préparer une
invasion de l'ukraine
[Applaudissements]
les russes ont massé cent mille soldats
le long de la frontière
ils ont déplacé des troupes en
biélorussie ils ont continué
l'escaladent malgré nos efforts pour
tenter de trouver une voie diplomatique
en parallèle les occidentaux brandissent
la menace de nouvelles sanctions
les parlementaires américains pourrait
voter cette semaine une loi ciblant les
banques russes et prévoyant le
renforcement de l'assistance militaire
américaine à l'ukraine londres a aussi
indiqué dimanche vouloir proposer à
l'otan un déploiement majeur de troupes
et de moyens militaires en europe de
l'est mais moscou continuent d'exiger
que l'ukraine ne rejoigne jamais l'otan
et que l'alliance retire ses troupes et
des armes de l'est du continent oui nous
connaissons maintenant le mari des
paroles de l'occident pour la russie
demandera l'occident non seulement des
promesses mais un engagement politique
mais aussi des garants du délai de
sécurité juridiquement contraignante
pour assurer la sécurité sur l'ensemble
du continent européen dans le respect
total des intérêts légitimes de la
russie
le président ukrainien a appelé la
russie à poursuivre le dialogue avec les
occidentaux mais sur le terrain les deux
camps se préparent à la guerre